si vous trouvez qu'il fait froid ce
matin écoutez bien ce qui suit 270
passagers d'un train se sont retrouvés
coincés pendant huit heures sans
électricité sur une voie ferrée du
labrador
ça s'est produit hier entre chef hervé
les sept îles alors qu'il faisait
justement moins 30 degrés je joue un
philippe grenier journaliste de
radio-canada saint-jean terre-neuve
philippe ça n'a pas dû être facile ça
non vraiment 8h images les huit
longueurs 270 passagers du train dont
des enfants des hommes et même aussi
deux femmes afin qu'ils se sont
regroupés ils se sont collés le plus
possible avec des couvertures alors que
les températures à l'extérieur acier
entre -20 dessus c'est moins 33 degrés
celsius donc c'était c'était très froid
on sait que c'est un problème électrique
que causé le bris est encore plusieurs
questions sans réponse l'un des
mécaniciens lui dit avoir tenté de
redémarrer de train le mieux qu'ils
pouvaient mais en vain à ce moment le
trait se trouvait à 65 km de la ville de
labrador city qui a finalement pu
quelques heures après le bris envoyer
des autobus pour venir en aide aux
passagers en détresse
c'est d'ailleurs à la balance sceptiques
qu'ils ont passé la nuit à la majeure
partie au saut d'autres passagers ont
passé la nuit à fermont au québec
heureusement aucun blessé certains ont
été transportés certains passages ont
été transportés à l'hôpital par mesure
de précaution mais plusieurs dizaines
bon évidemment c'est un vendredi 13 qui
vont se rappeler pour longtemps ouais je
peux imaginer
merci beaucoup au filet je suis en paix
au revoir nos jours